[Music]
in commercial controversy news submitted
by I need a Red Bull that's a red bill
with the Red Bull hallmark has changed
course after blocking Leslie blending
ads from its channel that's a good
stance man o hallmarks like a Christian
channel it feels Christian e hallmark
honestly makes some of the greatest
comedy today yes
the cards are hazing anybody no no I
thought was a movies the TV show there's
a Hallmark Channel the channel well I
thought you meant like Hallmark
commercials like the card has
commercials on TV no no no no channel I
will show you the trailer it's from its
channel you read that from show you a
channel I'm drunk off this red I'll show
you I'll show you a trailer that I
actually I think it said it to you right
Jim I don't think I said to you but I
told you about it it's like lifetime a
girl finds out that she's living inside
of her or she wakes up one day and she
wakes up inside of her Christmas village
[ __ ] that's the kind of [ __ ] they got
on homework dude it's like she wakes up
and this actress has to say out loud
she's like I'm in my Christmas village
but yet Cory Taylor it's getting louder
they talked about they will say this
notice if something like that gets made
and danger boys doesn't get picked up
I'm gonna be pissed a market for that
then there is for danger boys that's
because there's a lot of like moms that
have no kids anymore the kids left the
house and they're like they're just
alone and they're like uh neither woman
in a Christmas village Christian
channels like satan-worshipping channels
and Comedy Central it sounds big and
Spike TV there's this wedding planning
company called Zola
so Zola had this ad that was playing on
Hallmark Channel
but then this very conservative group so
it's called 1 Million Moms
so
I had this whole campaign to remove this
particular commercial because it
portrayed a lesbian couple and so they
actually liked Hallmark actually did it
they remove the ad where the lesbians
hotter ugly they were hot yeah they're
hot I saw you see they're jealous yeah
and also this should be a million moms
that want to make their son's soccer
games more interesting like this is
that's why they're so [ __ ] bored like
think about their lives man yeah well
they keep they continuously go after so
they're this is what it is it's by a
conservative group called the American
Family Association and it builds itself
as an advocate for parents who are fed
up with the filth many segments of our
society especially the entertainment
media are throwing at our children but
dude what is filth right so like what I
know
so they they were also protesting
against Ellen DeGeneres way back in the
day when she was JC Penney a
spokesperson because they were like how
can imagine carrying that much about who
someone loves right the [ __ ] or like JC
Penney's man yeah JC Penney how much I
know they were still around like hey
don't [ __ ] up JC Penney's JC Penney's
just like Sears their own wine stocks or
some [ __ ] like that do you remember that
[ __ ] oh yeah what's that let's go
there was a wine stocks was like a
shitty R version of Sears and it was
around for you know it was around all
over the place what is a shittier
version of sear my stocks maybe what
lately have you walked in it in the past
15 years Sears is nuts no Sears in
Pasadena that's that has a blowout so
closing down [ __ ] and I walked in just
to see what they have oh my god dude
they just didn't cut any prices down
dude like how dare you dude the CEO of
Ross goes into a series he's like
get it together okay so this is the
commercial I wonder if our guests would
be here on time if we had a custom
wedding website with our ceremony
details on it and I tailor would pick
Sola to happen to host our wedding
website ours even matched our Sola
invites the whole thing was so freakin
easy do you
[Music]
yeah with free websites registry and
invitations what's gonna happen next
this dogs gonna get married
basically humans are gonna marry dogs I
think Japanese person already did that
so just cuz it's funny yeah some people
think it's funny as something sticky
commercial Jo told me this morning
basically like we're like in the middle
of starting at JK news episode and he's
like he's like man one time this girl
like I wanted to have sex with her
visited she wanted me to wear a diaper
[ __ ] crazy is the baby alright so he
did it no he didn't but he just says
that he goes our next topic
yeah just like moves on and you're like
that's the same thing I've heard in 10
years but thank you for moving on I
guess taking off his diaper as you
saying it crinkling a little bit so
hallmark did not want to portray any
controversial seams and then that's when
glad like the CEO and president of GLAAD
Oh God making it controversial by taking
it off the message exactly exactly so
then there was just like well why would
you do that cuz then like you're just
literally feeding more into it yeah I
guess like if I'm looking at it from a
business perspective if they understand
that a majority of the viewership comes
from Christian households and stuff then
that would make sense that they didn't
want to do too controversial maybe maybe
that's what they thought but in the end
they still ended up
going back on it and then now they're
working with Zola to try to get these
commercials back on because Zola ended
up pulling out like they write the rest
of the commercials cuz I think they had
like four or six of them okay
and yeah so now they're trying to work
with them again to like rectify it again
because the entire like LGBTQ community
they all started having like hashtag
boycott doing [ __ ] hashtag boycott
this they cancel everything
listen cancel my [ __ ] listen I'll
boycott home I'm gonna stop making
hilarious movie how about that how about
that one just say boycott Homer just
because oh dude now they got a double
down though
now the next ad has to have a chicky to
another check out like you better go for
it then okay you're cool with gay [ __ ]
here we go well yes because hallmark had
already previously announced that they
were open to LGBTQ holiday movies so
then for them to do this it's just kind
of like why would he do that I think it
was just somebody who who looked at
these two stats and they're like I think
we have to gamble with this than the
other [ __ ] that's really all that it is
people will just take this stuff way too
personally it's not that personal it's
the numbers thing how many people our
audience have a stick way wedged up
there and then they do pull me and turn
Polian exactly and if it's more of those
people then they're gonna have to go
with that that's all that it is man it's
not true no they are trying to make it
right so you know what I hate though now
is this new trend where it's like hey we
have gay tires and I'm like well they're
just trying to make everything just like
LGBTQ everything just [ __ ] you know
everyone has it tires don't you hate
those [ __ ] homophobic red cups see
that we added ridges for dildos are used
to Jack Cox off and friendly cuff these
people your sexualizing the [ __ ] kind of
regular people who just have a different
preference like what they're just trying
to make money any way they can
yeah it's just like the [ __ ] the Pens
for her and they're just pink pen yeah
it's so silly it's just silly oh this is
straight [ __ ] this is be hated that [ __ ]
with the Legos because I loved Legos and
then they're like Legos for girls I'm
like the [ __ ] wrong with the regular
version right it's the same I view the
same hands right yes he wanted to Billy
key I was so pissed
no Legos had an instruction that was
just bill whatever the [ __ ] I wanted
that's too creative see if they really
wanted really wanted to have Legos for
girls they would have Legos that can
tell the girls to calm down every
Thursday we all see you know what's
funny is that David was just talking
about how he wants a girl a real boy
because they're so calm and I even said
that thun I have a bowl listen he's
talking about them when they're young
yeah before all the things happen oh
they started dating guys who made us
crazy guys make those crazy though yeah
I think girls is crazy oh you want to go
there again
David so if girls had their own planet
they were just [ __ ] destroyed it
wasn't long we don't like so many cats
and knitting come you literally buddy
the best place literally be war zone
[Music]
yeah right we don't know women roll over
home you know if men ruled the world
women would never been allowed to vote
20 women they're just competing over
wanting a guy that's all like they see
other women as competition so they're
kunti to them but if there was no
competition over anything they'd just be
like okay we could all [ __ ] build
kicks together no way no way you're just
jealous of our cakes they're good cakes
on different level slum cake dome cakes
good yeah yeah I see a woman made this
rum cake yeah who made this did you know
we bought it we don't know the [ __ ]
so [ __ ] funny I hate that why is it
sad hey why do you look almost disgusted
that I thought that you've been oh you
better be you cook every week on her
channel yes thank you
that's what I'm saying is like I'm ready
to be it to be a mom I did all the
things alright I'm like I can't cook
I'll learn how to cook I can't make the
bet I learn how to make the bet you know
I don't really like I really try it's
not like I had to think really hard to
learn how to make a bad but I was like I
want to look like the hotel beds and
then I was like I don't really want to
spend my mind energy doing this oh that
thing at the end of the bed at hotels is
for shoes
yes disgusting really what are you
absolutely talking about oh so you can
lay on the bed with you yeah so there's
like a strip at the end that is
disgusting disgusting but it's for shoes
no why I don't know you remove that and
it's not on your sheets I guess that's
the law but it's just weird that people
are on their bed with the shoes on crash
has people I agree that's some weird
[ __ ] dude even I get high-end hotels
yeah I asked me a cleaning lady about it
and then she told me what that was for I
thought she was [ __ ] you tip your
cleaning lady's if I stay there more
than a day yeah that's nice every day I
do a solid 12 second home after a date I
was like oh let's go into bed together
and then he got my bed with shoes
[ __ ] on done absolutely Wow
why are you on a date with a guy well
[Laughter]
just like this first I don't wanted a
baby next year okay I got it
so why do you want to date with this guy
like I'm right here I believe very much
in Thibodaux experiment they wear shoes
their shoes in bed Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]